I do want to talk a little bit more
about Donald Trump revealing classified
information to the Russians last week in
the Oval Office and specifically about
Edward Snowden and Donald Trump's
hypocrisy in relation to statements he's
made in the past about NSA leaker Edward
Snowden I want to call your attention to
three 2013 tweets from Donald Trump
which I will show you and read to you
here in 2013
July 10th specifically Donald Trump
tweeted Snowden has given serious
information to China and Russia anyone
who thinks otherwise is a dope he is a
traitor who fled he knew the crime Trump
followed up this tweet by saying call it
any way you like but Snowden is a
traitor when our country was great do
you know what we did to traitors talking
about execution and the third tweet from
Donald Trump Obamacare is a disaster and
Snowden is a spy who should be executed
but if it and he could reveal Obama's
records I might become a major fan this
might be the most nonsense Trump ever
packed in to a 140 character bursts
three different topics there I'm not
even going to address Trump saying he'd
be willing to forgive Snowden if Snowden
found Obama's birth certificate I mean
that's flat-out childish and
embarrassing but in these tweets Trump
is saying that Snowden should be
executed for giving sensitive American
secrets to the Russians that's
interesting because that's exactly what
Trump did a week ago when he met these
Russian diplomats including Russian
ambassador Sergey kis lyac a suspected
Russian spy recruiter at the White House
the only differences Trump is present
Edward Snowden himself noticed the irony
he tweeted on Monday as news of this was
breaking next time somebody says
revealing unconstitutional mass
surveillance to the press crossed the
line show them this link with a link to
the Washington Post article about Donald
Trump's leaks to the Russians the White
House initially denied that Trump
divulged secret information but then
Trump effectively admitted it saying
here's why I gave them this information
Trump's sending to tweets as we talked
about on yesterday's program quote as
president I wanted to share
with Russia and an openly scheduled
White House meeting which I have the
absolutely right to do facts pertaining
to terrorism and airline flight safety
humanitarian reasons plus I want Russia
to greatly step up their fight against
Isis and terrorism it's good to know I
guess
that Donald Trump and Mike Pence's
surrogates are so willing to lie for
Trump as many have done in the wake of
the scandal we've seen current and
former US officials come out from all
over the place emphasizing how dangerous
it is to be handing out intelligence in
this way
it strains the relationships we have
with countries that can provide us
intelligence and right now it's crucial
to have access to that intelligence as
we fight Isis but the hypocrisy here
with the Edward Snowden thing and the
bragging we learned that this was
because Trump wanted to sort of brag to
the Russians about the great Intel that
he gets to get your President of the
United States it also reveals a inherent
problem with the system because by Trump
leaking information to the Russians yeah
that was technically legal because he's
allowed to declassify information no
president yeah but it wasn't very well
thought out and it was certainly
dangerous and of course he's going to go
on skates
whereas ed until Edward Snowden did
something that was illegal but was for
the good of the country and of course
now he has to hide in an embassy
somewhere there's this is a point that
some people have been writing to me
saying David you're wrong because what
Trump did isn't illegal I never said it
was illegal so I don't know what you're
saying I'm wrong about that the
president is able to we imagine that
we're going to have a president who sort
of understands the consequences of their
actions President Obama did for example
Donald Trump doesn't we assume that a
president would make the decision to
reveal classified information
only if they fully understand what the
implications are of revealing that
classified information by default sort
of declassifying it Donald Trump did not
break any laws by saying what he did to
the Russians but he potentially
endangered intelligence sources he
potentially is impacting the national
security of Americans because again we
are talking about an Isis plot that he
was talking about there and he
potentially is going to impact our
relationships with allies and not only
the ally involved in giving us that
information which we now now believed to
be Israel but if you're a different ally
Pat and you hear that something that
Israel told the US and said specifically
don't spread this around Trump tells an
adversarial nation in the Oval Office
are you going to say hey let's talk to
the Americans about this no you're going
to say hey you know what maybe we should
play this a little closer to the vest
yeah it's sad when you can't trust the
most powerful country on earth and the
country that's supposed to be leading
the cause when it comes to things like
freedom and liberty and standing up for
what's right because you're worried as
to what the president is going to reveal
about you in the Oval Office the
president might spill the beans that is
now a concern for American allies and it
is it's disturbing to say the least not
exactly a good trait loose lips are not
a good trait for a president to have